she's a 20 20 20 20 20 20 Democratic
presidential candidate author of the war
on normal people the truth about
America's disappearing jobs and why
universal basic income is our future
Andrew yang
[Applause]
[Music]
as long as you were coming out you were
doing this is that a shot at Biden and
Bernie that you know you can come on
it's a subtle way of reminding everyone
you let sit your audience can tell you
he keeps the studio a little bit chilly
am i right oh okay that's it well listen
I I missed you at the debate you aren't
the only one I did I think you know you
have a different voice in a voice that
needs to be heard one thing I like about
your voice you're the least Trump
obsessed of all the candidates let me
read your quote you said if you turn on
cable network news today you would think
he's our president because of some
combination of Russia racism Facebook
Hillary and emails some of that is true
but you're saying it's other things and
I would agree yeah I'm heading from here
to Iowa and we blasted away 40,000
manufacturing jobs in that state and
when you go to those towns after the
mill closed the shopping center closed
people started to leave this school
shrank and it had it's never recovered
and that's the story that's played out
in Ohio Michigan western Pennsylvania
Wisconsin that's why Trump won all of
those key states and what we did to
those manufacturing jobs we're now doing
two retail jobs call center jobs 30
percent of America's malls and stores
are closing because Amazon is closing
them and Amazon is paying zero in taxes
so these are the problems that people in
Iowa feel every single day and when I
talk to voters they do not obsess about
impeachment the same way that folks in
the media do right America still makes
tough it's just that it's robots doing
it I think I read in your article
something like 88% of factory jobs that
were lost from 2000 to 2010 were lost to
automation
yeah it's the issue for you right to you
yeah when you go to a factory in the
Midwest you don't see wall-to-wall
immigrants you see walls and that's just
speeding up to the extent that you do
need more manufacturing workers which
you do they tend to be educated
technicians people who are good on
laptops and not hammering things into
place
and in our country only 33% of Americans
are going to graduate from college we're
essentially a nation of high
school graduates and those opportunities
are not keeping pace so the other thing
I like about you is that you are also
the least identity politics obsessed
I feel no I don't see color my staff
tells me you're Asian
yes early on in my campaign some people
told me that an Asian couldn't win the
white house about me running it wasn't
even like I you can't be president right
you should be president uh well they
weren't excited initially because Asian
Americans don't really think about
politics as a natural arena for us on
earth but hopefully I'm changing that
you are changing yeah you make jokes and
but some Asians don't like that you get
pushback but they don't like jokes about
being good at math they're the positive
it's like being kidded about having a
big dick you know how dare you know
everyone's gonna know you know well what
math is an acronym it stands for a make
America think harder yes what we need to
do yeah you do
you got to get good at math
so let me ask you about the China deal
not because you're Asian
[Laughter]
no really really because it was a big
part of the week you know we obsess
about all these other things this is and
I like your criticism of the media you
say you know I always criticize Fox News
all those years and still do because
they don't they just don't report the
news that they don't want their people
to hear about yeah I feel the left is
getting that way too now we did sign a
finally sign a trade deal with China
what do you think of it what's your take
on well the details haven't come out
from this phase one I talked to a
producer here in the US and they said
that what's been signed does not
actually protect them or address their
concerns at all it's more about not
slapping additional tariffs on imports
that were coming into the country and I
don't know about the rest of you but I'm
much more concerned about our exporters
and producers people like farmers in
Iowa than I am about the Chinese
producers so to me we don't know what's
in this until we get some more
information in details what about the
technology's feeling do you know well
the technology is doing is one thing but
it actually is that in there did we
really get it clear it's not clear
details but I think the issue is it's
not facing what the future is which is
China is actually very innovative and
it's starting to manufacture all kinds
of things including those robots those
are immigrant robots in those how come I
keep reading that the Democrats are
getting their ass kicked on the
technological front as far as social
media as far as ads I remember in 2000
was it 12 Obama their campaign was so
technologically ahead and Peggy Noonan
and said I think we're gonna win because
I see so many yard signs and ever likely
yard signs we're on the computer lady
and somehow now it's not somehow the
Republicans were using this very early
on I remember ralph reed using it great
effect
many many like ten years ago and it's
because the the for fox news most the
concerns were zeroed out in mainstream
media and so they started to use digital
tools rather adeptly
and now they use them in lots of ways
and they're sort of aided of course as
Andrew knows by Facebook and others in
terms of these tools and the ability to
micro-target and they've gotten very
good at it and the Democrats have dr.
liberals own Silicon Valley now we were
the ones they were good at this [ __ ] the
Republicans were supposed to be the old
man
who said you know talked about the
machine when they were talking about it
tapering it if you want us to leapfrog
the Republicans again I have your
nominee because I guarantee you as your
nominee we'd be better at technology the
Republicans come to fall yeah you
personally could make that house that's
I mean that's a big promise I mean and a
lot of catching up to do apparently yeah
you know what would happen in 2016 is
the the Republicans did get very very
good and then at the time Facebook went
to the Clinton campaign and said hey you
want some help and the Clinton campaign
said now we got it all right and that
was not about right answer
you